la parole est à madame isabelle debré
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues malgré les
réformes courageuses des précédents
gouvernements réforme constamment
critiquée par la gauche notre système de
retraite fera rapidement face à des
déséquilibres financiers très importants
ceci en partie dû à la dégradation
considérable de la conjoncture
économique les besoins de financement de
l'assurance vieillesse qui s'élevait à
14 milliards en 2011 seront de 20
milliards en 2020 selon le conseil
d'orientation des retraites l'heure
n'est plus mes chers collègues aux
tergiversations mais bien à la nécessité
de réfléchir ensemble un système moins
complexes juste et efficace nous savons
combien ce sujet est difficile et qu'il
nécessite courage
concertation et détermination vous avez
combattu toutes les réformes des
retraites que les précédents
gouvernements ont voulu élaborer alors
que la question était posée depuis le
gouvernement de michel rocard au début
des années 90 sans que la gauche
lorsqu'elle était au pouvoir ait pris la
moindre initiative en ce domaine il
n'est pas dans nos intentions de nous
opposer systématiquement aux
propositions qui seront débattues car ce
sujet est majeur pour notre pays pour
l'avenir de nos enfants à la lumière des
nombreux rapports établis par les
experts auxquels s'ajoutera celui de la
commission présidée par madame moreau et
dans le contexte actuel marqué par un
taux de chômage jamais atteint un coût
du travail trop élevé et une pression
fiscale difficilement supportable pouvez
vous madame la ministre nous exposer
clairement les axes des réformes retenu
par le gouvernement pouvez vous nous
indiquer en particulier si vous
envisagez l'unification des réformes de
retraites du secteur public et du
secteur privé vous n'avez pas répondu
tout à l'heure l'intégration des régimes
spéciaux dans le régime général ce que
soulever mon collègue gilbert barbier la
transition vers un système de retraite
universel par points et bien sûr le
report de l'âge légal de la retraite
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice debré si j'entends bien ce que
vous me dites au fond l'opposition
d'aujourd'hui majorité d'hier serait
prête à soutenir le gouvernement
dès lors qu'il s'engagerait dès lors
qu'il s'engagerait dans une réforme que
ump jugent très courageuse est ce que
l'ump juges courageux c'est ce que l'ump
d'hier n'a pas réalisé parce que ce que
vous venez de dire à l'instant c'est au
fond que ce qui doit nous permettre ce
qui doit nous permettre d'apprécier si
une réforme est adapté ou pas c'est de
savoir premièrement si nous mettons en
place une rave une un système par points
en 2010 la question du système par
points n'a pas été posée et a été écarté
et c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est
la raison pour laquelle un rendez vous
en 2013 avaient été fixés pour faire une
évaluation de la situation destiné à
produire un rapport monsieur le sénateur
madame la sénatrice deuxième point vous
m'expliquer que une réforme des
retraites au fond ça se limite à la
question somme toute assez sommaire de
celle du service public comme si la
seule question à laquelle nous étions un
confronté était de savoir si les règles
qui s'appliquent à la fonction publique
était de même nature ou non que celle
qui s'applique au secteur privé nous
avons la volonté madame la sénatrice de
prendre à bras le corps la situation que
vous nous avez laissé je les dis nous
voulons que la réforme qui s'engagent ne
soit pas simplement une réforme
comptable car l'exemple de 2010 est là
pour le prouver à vouloir simplement
mettre en place des mesures de
rééquilibrage financier à court terme on
s'expose à de tristes déconvenues et
nous nous sommes retrouvés dès 2013 avec
un déficit des régimes de retraite de
l'ordre de 14 milliards d'euros alors
que nous étions censés trouver des
déficits qui avait disparu nous avons
donc la volonté madame la sénatrice
d'engagés une réforme qui soit une
réforme volontaires qui s'inscrivent
dans la durée et qui permettent de
concilier exigences sociales
responsabilités financières madame debré
pour une réplique
madame la ministre je suis vraiment un
petit peu surprise de cette caricature
et surtout je vous ai posé quatre
questions extrêmement précise et
malheureusement vous n'avez répondu à
aucune des questions alors ce que
j'espère madame le ministre vous dites
vouloir écouter écouterez vous les
français qui ce matin vous l'avez vu
dans un sondage à 52 % préfèrent
l'allongement de la durée de travail
plutôt que l'augmentation des
cotisations écouterez vous le président
la république qui a dit je le cite on
vit plus longtemps on doit donc
travailler plus longtemps est enfin
madame le ministre
et enfin madame la ministre je trouve
que cette réforme commence un peu mal
ici au sénat a été voté au point de vue
de sur le sujet des retraites une
proposition de loi permettant le cumul
de ce qu'on a appelé le minimum
vieillesse c'est à dire la spa avec une
revenus d'activité vous nous dites qu'il
ya des toutes petites retraites et que
vous voulez vraiment aider ces petites
retraites cette proposition de loi a été
voté au sénat et vous avez fait en sorte
qu'elle ne soit pas l'assemblée
nationale et nous en sommes tous ici
vraiment désolé et ça prouve encore une
fois peut-être que votre c'est un peu
choquant parce que vous ne trouvez pas
les moyens de faire en sorte qu'une
proposition de loi simple humaine
efficace de bon sens et qui est basé sur
la solidarité
je vous remercie